- Y.Braun-Pivet: La première
question va être posée
par monsieur Franck Allisio.
- Franck Allisio: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de l'Economie.
Le spectre de la crise financière
de 2008 est-il à nouveau en train
de rôder autour de l'Europe et de
la France?
Trois banques outre-Atlantique ont
fait faillite ces derniers jours.
La Silicon Valley Bank s'est
effondrée en 48 heures vendredi.
15 ans après la faillite de Lehman
Brothers, les Etats-Unis n'ont
rien appris, ou si peu.
Les banques européennes sont
dotées de règles prudentielles
plus strictes.
Vous avez affirmé hier que cette
panique bancaire aux Etats-Unis
était une crise lointaine, des cas
isolés.
Toutes les banques européennes
ont-elles les reins solides et un
bilan sain?
Le Credit Suisse est une grande
institution qui connaît de
profondes difficultés.
C'est une banque systémique qui
remplirait tous les critères du
faible.
Ma question concerne le risque
d'effet domino, de propagation via
des banques européennes qui
seraient identifiées comme des
maillons faibles par les marchés.
Avons-nous une vue d'ensemble
précise de la solidité des banques
européennes?
Pouvez-vous nous garantir qu'il
n'y aura aucun risque de manque de
liquidités et d'insolvabilité pour
nos banques françaises dans les
prochaines semaines?
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Bruno Le
Maire.
- Bruno Le Maire: Merci.
Monsieur le député Allisio, il n'y
a pas de risque sur le système
bancaire français.
Comparaison n'est pas raison.
La SVB, la Silicon Valley Bank,
avait trois caractéristiques.
Elle était exposée à un seul
secteur d'activité, celui des
technologies.
Elle avait comme seul et unique
placement les bons du trésor
américain.
Cela fait que lorsque les taux ont
remonté, le placement était moins
positif.
Les épargnants ont retiré leurs
avoirs.
La banque s'est retrouvée à court
de liquidités.
Enfin, elle n'était soumise qu'à
la supervision du superviseur de
San Francisco, un superviseur
régional.
Seules 13 banques américaines sur
les 3500 banques américaines sont
soumises aux règles de supervision
globale, là où 430 banques
européennes sont soumises à ces
règles plus strictes.
Le système bancaire français est
un système universel, avec six
grandes banques qui représentent
plus de 90% des dépôts des
épargnants et des entreprises.
C'est un système universel et un
système diversifié.
Chacune de ces banques a des
placements très diversifiés.
Les ratios de liquidités et de
solvabilité sont parmi les
meilleurs au monde.
Les banques françaises, depuis la
crise de 2008, on mit 550
milliards d'euros de fonds propres
supplémentaires disponibles pour
assurer leurs ratios de
solvabilité.
Je veux vous rassurer, rassurer
nos compatriotes: le système
bancaire français est solide.
Il n'y a pas de risque sur les
banques françaises.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Jean-Paul
Mattei.
- Jean-Paul Mattei: Merci.
Madame la Première ministre, la
réforme des retraites que nous
allons finaliser cette semaine
après des mois de concertations et
de travail est à nos yeux
essentielle et nécessaire.
Il ne s'agit, ni plus ni moins,
que de sauver notre régime par
répartition, quasiment unique au
monde, pour la solidarité qu'il
crée entre les générations.
Sans cette réforme, et 1,5
cotisant par retraité en 2035,
cela ne suffira plus.
Le déficit cumulé sera de plus de
150 milliards.
La réforme que nous portons est
avant tout une réforme de
responsabilité vis-à-vis des
retraités d'aujourd'hui et des
jeunes générations qui n'ont pas à
porter la charge des inconsciences
passées.
Elle est en outre étalée dans le
temps pour être plus acceptable.
Madame la Première ministre, nous
devons rassurer les Français.
Oui, nous leur demandons de
travailler plus longtemps, mais
nous devons aussi leur donner des
garanties.
C'est ce que nous souhaitons
entendre aujourd'hui.
Qu'en est-il des mesures pour ceux
qui ont commencé à travailler tôt?
Qu'en est-il de la prise en compte
de la pénibilité?
Sera-t-elle garantie pour les
carrières dite actives?
La situation des femmes est-elle
enfin améliorée, après toutes ces
réformes qui les ont ignorées?
Vont-elles être enfin rétablies,
dans leur droit à une retraite
digne?
Enfin, allons-nous améliorer le
taux d'emploi des seniors, dont
les deux tiers ne travaillent
plus, pour mettre ainsi un terme à
ce gâchis humain?
Tous ces points sont l'assurance
du respect de notre contrat
social.
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Elisabeth
Borne.
- Elisabeth Borne: Merci.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
monsieur le président Mattei.
Nous arriverons dans quelques
jours au terme d'un long processus
de travail, de concertation et de
débats.
Il y a un an, le président de la
République s'est présenté aux
suffrages des Français en portant
l'engagement d'une réforme pour
garantir l'avenir de nos retraites
par répartition.
A l'automne 2022, avec le ministre
du Travail Olivier Dussopt, nous
avons lancé des concertations avec
les organisations syndicales,
patronales et les groupes
parlementaires.
Elles nous ont permis de présenter
un projet de loi enrichi par leurs
propositions.
Je sais qu'avec vos collègues de
la majorité, vous y avez
contribué.
Depuis, le débat parlementaire se
poursuit.
Au Sénat, le texte a été discuté
jusqu'au bout et adopté en fin de
semaine dernière.
L'Assemblée nationale a déjà
consacré plus de temps à débattre
de ce projet que lors des deux
précédentes réformes des
retraites, même si l'obstruction
organisée a accaparé le débat.
Mesdames et messieurs les
députés...
Huées
Dans cette Assemblée, une majorité
existe qui croit au travail, y
compris au travail des seniors.
Une majorité existe qui croit au
système de retraites par
répartition et qui veut garantir à
notre jeunesse qu'elle en
bénéficiera.
Une majorité existe qui refuse de
financer les retraites par plus
d'impôts, plus de charges et moins
de pensions.
Une majorité existe qui croit que
ceux qui ont commencé à travailler
tôt devront partir plus tôt à la
retraite.
Une majorité existe qui veut mieux
protéger celles et ceux qui ont un
métier difficile.
Nous voulons aussi permettre à
ceux qui ont été usés par le
travail de partir plus tôt à la
retraite.
Une majorité existe, qui sait que
la plupart des régimes spéciaux ne
sont plus d'actualité et qu'il
faut les fermer.
Une majorité pense qu'il faut
augmenter les pensions des petits
retraités comme celles des futurs
retraités.
Il faut réduire les inégalités de
pension entre les femmes et les
hommes.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: S'il vous
plaît!
- Elisabeth Borne: Une majorité
existe qui n'a pas peur des
réformes, même impopulaires, quand
elles sont nécessaires.
Une majorité existe qui fera
toujours passer la responsabilité
avant la posture ou les petits
calculs du coup d'après.
Une majorité existe qui ne se
laisse ni intimider par les
insultes, ni par les menaces, ni
par le vandalisme sur les
permanences.
Une majorité existe pour garantir
aujourd'hui l'avenir de nos
retraites et pour assumer demain
des désaccords ou des oppositions
franches sur d'autres sujets.
La commission mixte paritaire se
réunira demain sur notre projet
sur les retraites.
Vous serez ensuite
conduits à vous exprimer sur la
réforme des retraites, pas sur un
soutien au gouvernement mais sur
ce projet seulement.
Ce projet, nous pouvons en être
fiers.
Il a été considérablement enrichi,
amélioré, complété par des
propositions des partenaires
sociaux, de la majorité comme des
oppositions.
Alors, avec mon gouvernement, nous
sommes engagés pour que dans les
prochains jours, une majorité vote
la réforme des retraites.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Gérard
Leseul.
- Gérard Leseul: Merci.
Mesdames et messieurs les
ministres, chers collègues.
"Refuser de discuter, c'est faire
des Français les victimes d'une
absence de dialogue."
Vous avez prononcé ces mots ici
même, le 11 octobre dernier,
madame la Première ministre.
L'ensemble des syndicats
s'opposent à votre réforme des
retraites.
Le Conseil d'orientation des
retraites indique il n'y a pas
d'urgence.
Plus de 75% des Français actifs
sont hostiles à cette réforme.
La retraite à 1200 euros pour
tous, on le sait maintenant, c'est
un mirage.
De plus, les femmes seraient les
premières victimes de cette
réforme injuste.
Il existe des mesures alternatives
pour protéger et augmenter les
ressources de notre système des
retraites: l'augmentation du SMIC,
l'augmentation du salaire des
femmes ou une mise à contribution
des plus fortunés d'entre nous,
comme nos voisins espagnols l'ont
déjà fait.
Et votre gouvernement s'obstine à
repousser l'âge de départ en
retraite.
Alors que les évidences sont là,
alors que le bon sens démocratique
devrait inviter à suivre nos
concitoyens mobilisés contre cette
réforme, vous vous cachez les yeux
en attendant que la tempête passe.
Les marins savent très bien que
pour revenir au port, il faut
connaître la mer.
Vos concitoyens défilent chaque
semaine dans nos rues.
Il faut dialoguer avec les
représentants et les acteurs
syndicaux.
Refuser de discuter, c'est faire
des Français les victimes.
Quand allez-vous écouter les
Français pour éviter le naufrage
démocratique?
Quand allez-vous retirer ce projet
de loi pour reprendre la
discussion avec les partenaires
sociaux?
Acclamations
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Merci.
Monsieur le député Leseul, vous
avez dit que pour retourner au
port, il faut écouter la mer.
Mais le cap, nous l'avons déjà.
Le cap, c'est ramener le système
de retraites à l'équilibre.
Vous le savez, ce système est
déficitaire.
Nous le répéterons jusqu'au bout
du débat et même après.
Notre système est structurellement
déficitaire.
13,5 milliards d'euros de déficit
en 2030 et 20 milliards en 2035.
Si nous ne faisons rien, c'est 150
milliards d'euros de dettes
accumulées.
C'est une baisse des pensions pour
les retraités actuels, si nous ne
faisons rien.
C'est un décrochage du niveau de
vie des retraités par rapport au
reste de la population.
Vous dites qu'il n'y a pas de
débat.
Il y a eu du débat, de la
concertation avec les
organisations syndicales.
Il y a eu du débat au Sénat, qui a
voté le texte dans son
intégralité.
Le Sénat a voté l'âge de départ à
la retraite à 64 ans.
S'il n'y a pas eu de débat à
l'Assemblée, c'est la
responsabilité de la coalition
autour de La France Insoumise.
C'est vous qui avez fait le choix
de bloquer le débat et de ne pas
assumer cette responsabilité.
Vous dites qu'il ne faudrait rien
faire ou vous dites qu'il y a
d'autres solutions: on les
connaît, vos solutions!
Des impôts, encore des impôts.
Comme si augmenter les impôts
était la solution!
Augmenter les impôts, c'est la
baisse du pouvoir d'achat, c'est
du chômage en plus et c'est la
faillite de la France.
Ce que vous nous proposez, c'est
une alternative mortifère.
La baisse des retraites ou la
faillite du pays?
Nous avons fait le choix de la
responsabilité.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
Monsieur Leseul?
- Gérard Leseul: Face à votre
surdité, nous nous saisirons de
tous les moyens constitutionnels
pour dire non à votre réforme.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur le
président Chassaigne.
- André Chassaigne: Madame la
Première ministre, le peuple vous
signifie depuis des semaines son
refus de votre réforme injuste des
retraites.
Cette mobilisation ne faiblit pas.
Au Parlement, l'opposition est
telle, jusque dans vos rangs, que
vous avez pris la lourde
responsabilité de passer en force.
Ce fut d'abord le choix d'un PLFSS
rectificatif qui a limité le temps
des débats.
Ensuite, ce fut le refus d'ouvrir
le maximum d'heures de débat dans
l'hémicycle.
Ce fut encore l'utilisation du
vote bloqué au Sénat.
C'est toujours la menace du 49.3
pour clore une séquence
désastreuse.
Jamais un gouvernement n'aura usé
d'un tel entêtement pour
l'obstruction démocratique.
Vous avez affaibli votre
légitimité démocratique, et du
même coup, avez marqué votre
réforme du sceau de
l'illégitimité.
Les débats ont permis de mettre à
jour son inutilité et son
injustice, mais aussi les
mensonges les plus flagrants, les
1200 euros, pour lesquels nous
sommes partis de millions pour
finir à 13.000.
Vous avez fait rentrer des
amendements de la droite par la
fenêtre.
Le président de la République a
ajouté à cela du mépris en
opposant une fin de non-recevoir
aux organisations syndicales qui
sollicitaient de le rencontrer en
urgence.
Il est des victoires qui sonnent
comme des défaites.
De Jupiter à Pyrrhus, il n'y a
parfois qu'un petit pas.
Vous ne pouvez pas gouverner non
seulement sans, mais contre le
peuple et ses représentants.
C'est dangereux pour le pays.
C'est dangereux pour sa cohésion.
C'est dangereux pour notre
démocratie.
Plutôt que de céder à la brutalité
constitutionnelle, renoncez à
votre projet.
Faites le choix du respect, faites
le choix de l'apaisement.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci,
monsieur le président.
La parole est à madame la Première
ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Merci.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
monsieur le président Chassaigne.
Vous appelez au dialogue.
Reconnaissez qu'avec le ministre
du Travail, Olivier Dussopt, nous
avons régulièrement dialogué,
concerté avec les organisations
syndicales et patronales, avec les
représentants des groupes
parlementaires.
Je le dis, comme je l'ai déjà fait
et comme le président de la
République l'a aussi affirmé: la
porte du gouvernement, celle de
ministre du Travail, reste ouverte
pour recevoir l'intersyndicale si
elle le souhaite.
Monsieur le président Chassaigne,
vous appelez aussi au respect du
Parlement.
Assumez que c'est vous qui opposez
la légitimité de la rue à celle du
Parlement.
Vous demandez un débat et vous
avez eu des mots forts pour
dénoncer les insultes et les
outrances qui venaient de certains
bords de la NUPES.
Mais monsieur le président
Chassaigne, assumez que ces excès
participent à une stratégie
globale de blocage à l'Assemblée
comme au Sénat.
Assumez qu'avec vos partenaires de
la NUPES, vous voulez empêcher la
discussion et le vote.
Assumez que vous avez fait le
choix de l'obstruction alors qu'il
y a déjà eu plus de temps de débat
sur cette réforme des retraites
que sur les deux précédentes.
Monsieur le président Chassaigne,
parlons concrètement pour finir.
Voter contre cette réforme, c'est
dire à toutes les infirmières
libérales, à toutes les femmes qui
exercent des professions
libérales, qu'elles devront
renoncer à une majoration de 10%
de leurs pensions.
Assumez que voter contre cette
réforme, c'est dire à 1,8 million
de retraités que leur pension
n'augmentera pas cet été, en
moyenne de 600 euros par an.
Assumez que voter contre cette
réforme, c'est dire à des Français
qui ont commencé à travailler
avant 16 ans qu'ils devront
travailler 45 ans alors que nous
leur proposons de partir plus tôt
en travaillant moins longtemps.
Assumez que voter contre cette
réforme, c'est dire aux chauffeurs
de bus du Puy-de-Dôme qu'ils
devront travailler plus longtemps
et davantage que ceux de Paris.
Il y a des moments démocratiques
où il faut assumer, tout
simplement.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur
Jean-Pierre Pont.
- Jean-Pierre Pont: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
Olivier Véran.
Beaucoup de praticiens arrivent
aujourd'hui à l'âge de la retraite
et les nouvelles générations ne
sont pas encore assez nombreuses
pour compenser les départs.
Pour les patients, cela se traduit
par des difficultés croissantes à
trouver un médecin généraliste
traitant et cela entraîne une
multiplication des déserts
médicaux dans certaines régions.
Une première solution a été
apportée avec la disparition du
numerus clausus, mais ces
nouvelles générations de médecins
n'arriveront que dans 8 ans au
mieux.
Quelles autres pistes peuvent être
envisagées?
On plébiscite les maisons de
santé.
Ce système, amplement poussé par
l'Etat, permet d'assumer et
d'assurer une continuité dans le
parcours de santé.
Dans ma circonscription, 23
médecins se sont regroupés pour
proposer 40 consultations libres
par semaine.
Nous pourrions soutenir également
la création de cabinets
secondaires ou de cabinets
itinérants, se déplaçant chaque
jour dans un secteur désertifié
différent.
Médecin généraliste, il me semble
normal pour ma part d'intégrer le
groupe d'étude qui vient d'être
créé sur les déserts médicaux et
l'accès aux soins.
Je développerai plus précisément
ces idées au sein de ce groupe
d'études.
Monsieur le ministre, je vous
serais reconnaissant de bien
vouloir nous faire connaître, pour
lutter contre ces déserts
médicaux, quelles sont les
premières pistes que vous
envisagez.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Véran.
- Olivier Véran: Merci.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
monsieur le député Jean-Pierre
Pont.
François Braun est en déplacement
sur le territoire.
Sa ministre déléguée également.
C'est pourquoi je répondrai aux
questions qui ont lieu sur la
santé.
Vous avez raison de poser cette
question.
Enquête d'opinion après enquête
d'opinion, le sujet qui est
systématiquement sur le podium des
préoccupations de nos concitoyens,
c'est l'accès aux soins car nous
manquons de médecins sur le sol
français.
Ceci parce que, pendant près de 50
ans, l'Etat a empêché des jeunes
Français d'apprendre la médecine
en France.
Nous avons supprimé le numerus
clausus en 2018.
Il faut 10 ans pour former un
médecin.
Les fruits de cette décision
ne sont pas à récolter
tout de suite.
Comment agissons-nous dans
l'intervalle?
Nous agissons d'abord sur
l'organisation de soignants dans
les territoires, avec un maître
mot: épargner du temps médical,
réduire les tâches
administratives.
Ce sont ces milliers d'assistants
médicaux qui viennent partout où
les médecins sont regroupés pour
permettre d'épargner du temps
médical.
C'est cette délégation d'actes à
des soignants paramédicaux dûment
formés qui offre des soins de
qualité, y compris en accès direct
grâce à un récent vote de
l'Assemblée nationale qui va
permettre d'éviter d'aller chez le
médecin quand on peut consulter un
autre professionnel.
C'est aussi l'organisation et le
mariage sur tout le territoire
national.
Je crois aussi à la télémédecine.
Nous sommes passés de 10.000 actes
à près d'un million d'actes de
télémédecine par semaine avec le
Covid.
Il y a aussi la concertation et
l'innovation dans les territoires,
à travers les conseils nationaux
de la refondation.
Des centaines d'entre eux se
tiennent partout sur le
territoire.
Là où il se tient, on identifie
des solutions efficaces.
Il y a enfin l'objectif d'offrir
un traitement à des malades
longue durée.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur François
Rufin.
- François Ruffin: Mesdames et
messieurs du gouvernement, et
monsieur le président derrière
vous.
Vous êtes le coyote de Tex Avery.
Il court, il court, il a franchi
la falaise et sous lui, c'est le
vide.
Il découvre ce vide et soudain, il
chute.
Je vous regarde et c'est ce vide
qui me frappe, ce vide en vous, ce
vide sous vous.
Pour le dire autrement, il a été
écrit que la classe dominante
était seulement en triste d'une
pure force de coercition.
Vous, le gouvernement, vous, les
dominants, vous ne dirigez plus.
Vous ne cherchez même plus à
diriger, c'est-à-dire entraîner le
peuple, à obtenir son
consentement.
Vous faites sans.
Convaincre de la justice de votre
projet, vous avez à peine essayé
avec des arguments brouillons et
des chiffres bidons.
2 Français sur 3 sont opposés à la
réforme?
Tous les syndicats sont unis
contre vous?
3 millions de personnes dans la
rue?
Les raffineries sont bloquées?
Les déchets ne sont pas ramassés?
Et alors?
Le coyote de Tex Avery est
comique, lui.
Vous êtes tragique.
Vous êtes des dangers pour les
Français.
Que faites-vous?
Vous punissez les travailleurs qui
ont tenu le pays debout.
Vous instillez dans le coeur des
dégoûts, vous écrasez une
démocratie que vous devriez
soigner et vous avez entravé un
pays qu'il faut réparer.
Chers collègues de tous bords,
j'en appelle à votre
responsabilité.
Oui!
Pourquoi faire le grand saut avec
Macron?
Je dis, votez en votre âme et
conscience, au mieux pour la
France.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Merci.
Je crains que ma réponse soit
brève, puisque vous n'avez pas
posé de question.
Vous n'avez pas posé de question,
vous n'avez pas pu vous empêcher
de succomber à vos péchés, à
l'outrance, une forme d'insulte
déguisée et la volonté de vouloir
prendre une hauteur que vous
n'atteindrez jamais.
Vous avez terminé sur la
responsabilité.
La responsabilité, c'est celle de
cette majorité.
C'est celle de porter une réforme
qui permet d'équilibrer le
système, qui permet de créer de
nouveaux droits et qui permet de
regarder nos petits-enfants dans
les yeux en leur disant que nous
avons préservé un système de
solidarité dont ils vont pouvoir
bénéficier.
La responsabilité, c'est celle de
discuter pour améliorer le texte.
Nous l'avons fait au Sénat, avec
des mesures favorables à celles et
ceux qui travaillent, avec des
mesures de lutte contre la fraude,
avec des améliorations pour celles
et ceux qui ont des carrières
longues.
Vous vous contentez de contester.
Vous vous essayez même à déclamer.
Ca ne suffit pas pour agir, ça ne
suffit pas pour être responsable.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Jean-Jacques Gaultier.
- Jean-Jacques Gaultier: Madame la
présidente, ma question, elle
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre
de la Santé et de la Prévention et
elle concerne la situation
alarmante de l'hôpital public,
avec l'entrée en vigueur d'une loi
dans quelques jours.
L'encadrement des rémunérations
des médecins intérimaires est une
attention louable et même
souhaitable, mais pas dans les
conditions actuelles, qui vont
avoir des conséquences terribles
sur l'organisation de l'offre de
soins.
Dans la région Grand Est, 90% des
établissements sont touchés.
Dans les Vosges, la continuité des
services est assurée par le seul
recours à l'intérim dans de
nombreuses spécialités.
L'offre de soins est en grand
danger, avec des fermetures de
services à risque vital.
Fermeture de la maternité
d'Epinal, avec plus de 1200
accouchements par an, ou fermeture
des urgences de Vittel, qui
doivent pourtant fonctionner en
continu.
80% de la population couverte par
le service des urgences de Vittel,
44.000 habitants, 150 communes
rurales, se trouveraient à plus de
30 minutes.
Le site de Vittel, dans son
ensemble, serait menacé.
C'est inacceptable en termes de
santé publique et en termes
d'économie.
Cela confirmerait encore les
inégalités d'accès aux soins
d'urgence entre ruraux et urbains.
Prendrez-vous la responsabilité
d'acter une telle décision?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Véran.
- Olivier Véran: Merci.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
monsieur le député Gaultier.
Avec cette mesure, nous voulons
mettre un coup important, voire
fatal, aux dérives de l'intérim
médical.
Lorsque l'intérim devient la
norme, lorsque des médecins
exigent 2500 euros pour 24 heures,
ça met en péril la continuité des
soins, la sécurité financière de
l'établissement et ça crée une
spirale inflationniste.
C'est pourquoi les parlementaires
avaient décidé de mettre en place
une régulation avec un
plafonnement de 1170 euros pour 24
heures de travail, renouvelables.
Monsieur le député, les soignants
de votre territoire savent pouvoir
compter sur votre détermination à
préserver les structures de soins
dans la région de Vittel.
Sachez que les habitants de votre
territoire et les soignants de
votre territoire pourront compter
sur la détermination du
gouvernement et donc de l'Etat
pour faire en sorte que les
structures de soins auxquelles
vous faites allusion puissent être
organisées de manière à assurer
dans la durée la continuité et la
sécurité des soins.
Nous ne laisserons pas ces
structures fermées, péricliter ou
s'abîmer, ne serait-ce que parce
que vous êtes dans un territoire
soumis à une forte saisonnalité,
avec une population qui grandit
dans la période estivale.
Comptez sur notre détermination.
Nous continuerons de travailler
avec vous.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
Monsieur Gaultier?
- Jean-Jacques Gaultier: Après les
"merci" du Covid et les promesses
du Ségur, on ne peut se contenter
de constater la situation et de
voir comment ça se passe.
On ne peut pas jouer à pile ou
face avec la santé de nos
concitoyens et le moral de nos
personnels hospitaliers.
Le premier devoir de l'Etat est de
protéger les Français, notamment
en matière de santé.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Anne
Brugnera.
- La laïcité est un des fondements
de notre école.
Elle doit protéger nos élèves.
Cette laïcité contestée par une
France minoritaire mais agissante.
On le voit par les statistiques de
votre ministère.
Le nombre d'atteintes à la laïcité
est arrivé en octobre dernier
selon une enquête IFOP.
Un enseignant sur deux a été
confronté à une atteinte à la
laïcité.
Une seconde enquête confirme cette
tendance.
Face à ce phénomène, vous avez
annoncé un plan laïcité avec
plusieurs axes.
D'abord, des sanctions
systématiques et graduées pour les
élèves avec un comportement qui
porte atteinte à la laïcité si ce
comportement persiste après un
dialogue.
Il y a ensuite le renforcement de
la protection et du soutien au
personnel, l'appui aux chefs
d'établissement, et ce travail est
un travail de longue haleine.
Il faut du temps pour que les
outils produisent leurs effets,
que les méthodes soient intégrées.
Ainsi, l'enquête peut être
l'occasion, avec les sondés,
d'aller plus loin et de lever
leurs propres freins au
signalement.
Il est important de suivre la
situation de près et d'en parler.
En parler, c'est ancrer le sujet
de l'atteinte à la laïcité dans
les esprits de chacun.
Les enseignants doivent savoir
qu'ils sont soutenus dans cette
lutte délicate.
Je sais votre détermination sur ce
point.
Pouvez-vous nous indiquer les
perspectives sur lesquelles compte
travailler votre ministère?
- Pap Ndiaye: Merci à tous.
La question de la laïcité à
l'école est fondamentale.
C'est la condition sine qua non de
la formation libre et de
l'émancipation.
Face à l'augmentation des
atteintes à la laïcité en automne
dernier, nous avons agi pour ne
pas laisser de place à ceux qui
tentent de fragiliser les
fondements de la République et qui
ne veulent nullement bien à nos
élèves, ni à l'école, ni à la
République.
J'ai donc pris une série de
mesures.
D'abord, encourager le personnel
éducatif à signaler toute
atteinte.
600 personnes ont été ajoutées aux
effectifs.
Nous voulons rendre publics
mensuellement les chiffres
d'atteinte à la laïcité.
J'ai été clair sur les
instructions qui ont été passées
aux recteurs et aux chefs
d'établissement.
Il y a d'abord le dialogue avec
les élèves et avec leur famille.
L'école, c'est le lieu de la
pédagogie.
Ensuite, quand le dialogue ne
porte pas ses fruits, il y a
conseil de discipline et sanction.
Depuis la rentrée, les chiffres
d'atteinte à la laïcité ont baissé
de manière significative, mais je
n'en tire aucune conclusion
hâtive.
Il faut persévérer.
Une des enquêtes que vous évoquez
reflète l'avis de certains chefs
d'établissement.
Je les encourage à ne rien cacher.
Il ne faut surtout pas mettre la
poussière sous le tapis et offrir
toutes les garanties pour que les
signalements puissent s'exercer
sereinement.
Le combat contre les atteintes à
la laïcité est un travail de
conviction et de fermeté sur les
principes et les actes.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à Guy Bricout.
- Guy Bricout: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de l'Industrie.
Deux des plus grands employeurs
agroalimentaires de ma
circonscription ont annoncé la
fermeture de leur usine avec
suppressions de postes massives.
De nombreuses manifestations de
soutien ont été organisées.
Les salariés ont pleuré.
Je les plains.
Nestlé a rénové l'usine Buitoni et
a annoncé relancer la chaîne de
pizzas cuites.
150 salariés et leur famille sont
menacés.
Il n'est pas concevable qu'un
groupe comme Nestlé ne puisse
engager une solution pérenne pour
la sauvegarde d'une activité sur
le site.
Des solutions existent, et Nestlé
doit les mettre en oeuvre.
Dans la même semaine, toujours
dans ma circonscription, un autre
employeur de l'agroalimentaire, le
deuxième sucrier mondial, annonce
brusquement aux salariés l'arrêt
de l'activité.
Ce sont 400 emplois directs ou
indirects qui vont disparaître.
Les salariés ont donné le meilleur
d'eux-mêmes et ne méritent pas ce
mépris de la part de l'entreprise,
qui dégage de gros bénéfices.
Sur un territoire comme le mien,
très marqué par le chômage, plus
de 1000 emplois, en une semaine,
risquent d'être supprimés.
Merci de vous être déplacé hier
dans ma circonscription et d'avoir
discuté avec les parties
concernées.
Vous avez su faire preuve
d'autorité, et je vous en
remercie.
Les salariés de l'usine Nestlé et
de la sucrerie pourront-ils
compter sur une action du
gouvernement qui leur permettra de
sauvegarder leur emploi?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Laurent Lescure.
- Laurent Lescure: Merci de votre
engagement auprès des salariés.
Vous en avez témoigné hier avec
l'ensemble des élus municipaux et
régionaux.
Deux décisions ont sonné comme
deux coups de tonnerre dans un
territoire qui n'en avait pas
besoin.
J'ai rencontré les directions de
deux entreprises, avec des
situations différentes.
Pour Nestlé, il est impensable que
les salariés soient des victimes
collatérales d'un drame sanitaire
dont ils ne sont en aucun cas
responsables.
Il est indispensable que Nestlé
organise de la production sur ce
site, qu'on produise des pizzas et
autre chose.
Je leur ai donné deux semaines
pour me faire des propositions, et
je les attends de pied ferme.
Concernant la sucrerie, c'est une
entreprise qui a décidé de fermer
un site.
Ca arrive.
En revanche, je n'accepte pas les
raisons qui m'ont été données.
Une entreprise qui perdait de
l'argent il y a quelques années et
qui en gagne aujourd'hui, une
entreprise qui est sur un marché
porteur et dont le prix est en
hausse.
Je ne me satisfais pas des
explications qui m'ont été
données.
Je leur ai donné trois jours, et
le préfet va les recevoir avec les
élus concernés pour entendre les
explications.
Votre territoire est difficile.
J'ai annoncé hier un dispositif
particulier qui sera doté de 3
millions d'euros pour permettre
d'accompagner les industriels qui
souhaitent développer votre
territoire.
Vous en connaissez.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Jérémie Iordanoff.
- Jérémie Iordanoff: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Madame la Première ministre, vous
avez été nommée par le chef de
l'Etat.
Nous avons été élus par le peuple
français.
Emmanuel Macron est là grâce au
barrage face à l'extrême droite.
Il n'a pas de majorité sur son
programme.
Vous avez refusé d'engager la
responsabilité de votre
gouvernement devant la
représentation nationale.
Vous maltraitez la Constitution.
Vous avez mis la réforme des
retraites dans le projet de loi de
finances rectificative pour ne pas
griller un 49.3.
Madame la Première ministre, vous
n'écoutez pas les syndicats.
Vous brusquez la procédure
législative.
Vous faites fi des millions de
Français et Françaises qui
défilent pacifiquement dans les
rues.
Vous avez l'outrecuidance de
laisser entendre que vous pourriez
utiliser la procédure de
législation forcée.
Le président de la République veut
réformer les institutions.
Comment pouvez-vous ignorer la
demande de démocratie et de
débats, de délibérations dans
notre pays?
A l'heure où nombre de nos
concitoyens se détournent des
urnes, où le Rassemblement
National s'approche dangereusement
du pouvoir, entendez les alertes.
Ne jetez plus de l'huile sur le
feu!
Les tensions doivent se résoudre
dans un cadre institutionnel,
respectueux de la délibération et
de la séparation des pouvoirs.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Olivier Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Merci.
Permettez-moi de vous rappeler,
puisque vous semblez l'avoir
oublié, qu'après avoir été nommée
Première ministre, Elisabeth Borne
s'est présentée devant les
électeurs.
C'était lors des élections
législatives.
Dans son programme, comme dans
ceux de tous les députés de la
majorité, il y avait la réforme
des retraites.
Cet engagement a été pris par le
président de la République comme
par l'ensemble des députés de la
majorité présidentielle.
Vous dites qu'il n'y a pas de
débat?
Deux lois de concertation ont été
mises en place pour améliorer le
texte pendant de nombreuses
heures.
L'Assemblée et le Sénat auront
débattu presque 180 heures sur le
projet de réforme des retraites.
Votre assemblée aurait pu aller au
bout du texte si vous n'aviez pas
fait le choix de l'obstruction.
Le Sénat est allé au bout du
texte.
Nous avons mis en oeuvre des
articles de la Constitution qui
avaient déjà été mis en place en
2013 sur la loi de sécurisation de
l'emploi.
Vous n'écoutez pas la réponse que
je vous fais, mais dans cette
majorité, nous n'opposerons jamais
la légitimité du Parlement à la
rue.
Nous avons souvent le sentiment
que vous appelez vous-même au
désordre.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Marie-Agnès Poussier-Winsback.
- Marie-Agnès Poussier-Winsback:
Ma parole s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de la Transition
écologique et de la Cohésion des
territoires.
C'est une journée particulière
pour les communes littorales,
puisque c'est aujourd'hui que le
comité national est installé par
madame la ministre Bérangère
Couillard.
A Fécamp, là où je suis élue
municipale, un éboulement de
falaise a eu lieu ces derniers
jours.
Ces événements, autrefois
exceptionnels, deviennent
récurrents.
Faut-il sensibiliser plus notre
population?
Sans doute.
Nous le faisons déjà à travers
d'actions engagées par les
différents syndicats mixtes
littoraux auprès de nos habitants.
Il est urgent d'armer au plus vite
les communes face aux risques et
de trouver des financements pour
les accompagner.
C'est le rôle de ce comité.
Les maires ont besoin d'être aidés
dès lors que nos territoires
entrent dans les communes sujettes
à l'érosion et aux submersions
marines.
Nous devons avoir une approche
différente de celles que nous
avons pu avoir en matière
d'urbanisme et d'aménagement.
Il sera nécessaire d'aller au bout
d'un dispositif qui puisse
accompagner les différents
concernés avec un fonds d'érosion
côtière, par exemple.
De nouveaux ouvrages vont devoir
être financés.
Il faut associer la question du
recul et de la submersion marine.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
- Bérangère Couillard:
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
merci.
Je vous remercie pour votre
question qui me permet de mettre
en avant le lancement du comité
national du trait de côte.
Je vous assure de ma pleine
mobilisation sur un sujet
stratégique pour nos littoraux.
Je me suis rendue dans différentes
villes littorales.
Le constat est le même: il faut
anticiper.
Avec le réchauffement climatique,
le niveau de la mer et des océans
va monter.
20% des littoraux sont concernés.
En cas d'une hausse de 2 degrés,
l'eau pourrait monter de 1 mètre.
Nous n'avons pas attendu pour
agir.
De nouvelles mesures ont été
prises dans le cadre de la loi
climat et résilience.
Cela se fait sur la base du
volontariat.
Les communes peuvent s'identifier
via un décret pour travailler sur
ce sujet.
126 communes se sont déjà portées
volontaires.
J'espère que Fécamp en fera
partie.
Nous investissons en 2023 20
millions d'euros pour accompagner
les collectivités.
Les moyens déployés vont permettre
de répondre aux besoins présents,
mais nous devons aussi construire
une capacité pérenne de
financement des adaptations
nécessaires de nos littoraux.
Nous devons passer d'une politique
de gestion des risques à une
politique d'aménagement des
territoires.
En ce jour du lancement officiel
du comité national du trait de
côte, nous avons trois questions:
comment financer les besoins de
financement et quels sont les
leviers de financement?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à Hadrien Clouet.
- Hadrien Clouet: Mesdames et
messieurs les membres du
gouvernement, depuis plusieurs
semaines, des révélations se
succèdent.
Six mois dans ce pays que nous
plaidons en faveur d'un blocage
des prix de l'essence et d'une
taxation des superprofits, six
mois que vous tournez autour du
pot.
Plusieurs députés sont
actionnaires de Total.
Tu m'étonnes qu'ils votent contre
le fait de taxer les superprofits!
C'est le cas pour tous les grands
monopoles de cet hémicycle.
Je pense à Jean-René Cazeneuve,
qui a des millions d'actions chez
Bouygues.
Opérateur que nous sommes obligés
d'utiliser avec nos téléphones à
l'Assemblée.
A chaque SMS, je vous profite
personnellement.
Nous vous demandons qui ici a des
intérêts particuliers et
personnels?
Qui ici a des investissements sur
des plans d'épargne retraite?
Qui a des fonds de pension ici
dans les assurances et les régimes
bancaires?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Gabriel Attal.
- Gabriel Attal:
Merci, monsieur le président.
Madame la présidente, messieurs et
mesdames les députés, monsieur
Hadrien Clouet, vous parlez de
Total, mais vous allez finir par
trouver du pétrole à force de
toucher le fond.
Vous parlez d'actionnaires, mais
vous êtes le premier actionnaire
de la démagogie en France et vous
partagez les dividendes avec
l'autre extrême de l'hémicycle.
Cette démagogie est scandaleuse et
dangereuse.
Dangereuse parce qu'avec ce genre
d'attaques, vous en venez à
délégitimer des règles de
transparence qui ont été mises en
place contre les conflits
d'intérêts.
Ce sont ces règles auxquelles vous
vous attaquez.
Ce gouvernement n'a pas eu la main
qui tremble pour taxer les
superprofits, notamment ceux de
Total.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Monsieur
Clouet?
- Hadrien Clouet: On n'attendait
guère de réponse, mais je suis
surpris qu'il y ait des aveux.
Je retiens une chose de nos
échanges: invectiver les éboueurs
qui luttent pour leur droit à
l'existence, mais faire le ménage
dans vos comptes bancaires, c'est
au-dessus de vos forces?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
- Gabriel Attal: Vous avez passé
des heures à parler de la taxation
des superprofits et à parler de
Total.
Ce qui est dangereux pour notre
système de retraite, c'est votre
discours.
Quand il n'y a pas de
superprofits, qu'est-ce qu'on
fait?
On baisse les pensions?
Vous n'avez qu'une seule cible,
c'est la France qui travaille.
Vous avez proposé d'augmenter la
CSG à partir de 1600 euros de
revenu?
Et l'intéressement et la
participation?
Ca touchait 5 millions de
salariés!
La France n'est pas un paradis
fiscal, mais vous voulez en faire
un enfer pour les Français qui
travaillent.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Il n'y a
qu'une seule réponse, monsieur
Clouet, pas deux.
C'est le règlement.
La parole est à Stéphane Mazars.
- Stéphane Mazars: Ma question
s'adresse à Marc Fesneau.
Il y a 10 jours, la 59e édition du
salon de l'agriculture baissait
les rideaux.
Les Français étaient présents avec
un engouement particulier.
Vous avez été au contact de la
ferme France, comme bon nombre de
nos députés, heureux de voir les
acteurs de notre territoire se
diriger vers la capitale.
J'en profite pour vous remercier
de l'attention particulière que
vous avez accordée aux acteurs
agricoles de mon département.
Si notre agriculture s'est parée
de ses plus beaux habits, ça
n'enlève rien aux soucis que nos
agriculteurs rencontrent au
quotidien.
Les adaptations sont d'ores et
déjà en cours, mais doivent
s'accélérer.
Il y a une décapitalisation du
cheptel particulièrement
inquiétante.
Les nuisibles s'attaquent à la
production, voire aux animaux
eux-mêmes.
Il y a la question des normes qui
sont parfois préjudiciables à la
compétitivité de nos filières.
On peut comprendre qu'aujourd'hui,
il y ait une désaffection pour le
beau métier d'agriculteur, surtout
si on rajoute l'engagement que ce
métier suscite en termes de
travail et des sacrifices auxquels
il faut consentir.
L'agriculture française a besoin
d'un cap clair.
Vous avez pu vous exprimer à
plusieurs reprises sur votre
vision de l'agriculture.
Pouvez-vous nous en redire les
grandes lignes?
Pouvez-vous nous dire quelles
seront les grandes lignes de ce
projet de loi que nous allons
examiner et qui doit redonner de
l'attractivité à ce secteur?
- Marc Fesneau: Merci pour votre
question, qui permet de faire un
bilan sur le salon et de donner
des perspectives.
D'abord, il y a eu une forte
influence qui nous a tous permis
de rencontrer les agriculteurs
ainsi que leurs difficultés, leurs
innovations et leur volonté
d'avancer.
On a pu évoquer la question de la
souveraineté fruits et légumes.
On a pu avancer sur les questions
de modernisation de l'appareil
dans la ligne droite du plan
France 2030.
Nous avons pu montrer comment nous
voulons accompagner l'agriculture.
Vous l'avez dit, il faut donner un
cap à l'agriculture.
Je pense au cap de la
souveraineté.
Il s'agit de donner les moyens de
production, l'accès aux capitaux
et à l'eau, pour permettre aux
agriculteurs de faire face aux
défis qui sont les nôtres.
Ils doivent aussi faire face aux
dérèglements climatiques et aux
nouveaux besoins environnementaux.
Le statu quo en agriculture avec
le changement climatique serait un
grand défi si nous n'arrivions pas
à le relever.
Le troisième sujet, c'est celui de
la rémunération.
Nous avons commencé à en discuter.
Sans rémunération, il n'y aura pas
d'attractivité.
Vous avez dit: "Pas de pays, pas
de paysan."
Nous devons renouer avec
l'agriculture.
C'est le cap que nous voulons
tracer en termes de souveraineté.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
Adrien Quatennens.
- Adrien Quatennens: Merci.
Madame la Première ministre, dans
le courrier de réponses sur la
réforme des retraites, Emmanuel
Macron reprend le tissu de
mensonges que le gouvernement nous
sert depuis le début du débat
parlementaire.
Le premier, c'est le déficit qui
justifierait cette réforme.
Le déficit serait, en fait,
artificiellement gonflé.
Rapporté au PIB, le déficit est
moins impressionnant que
l'affichage du gouvernement.
Les administrations de la Sécurité
sociale resteraient largement
excédentaires.
Notre système de production
sociale est en bonne santé
financière, et le déficit annoncé
ne met en aucun cas en péril ce
système.
Quel est votre but?
De baisser les dépenses publiques
en général?
Ce n'est pas de sauver le système
de retraite pour repasser sous le
seuil de 3% de déficit, la fameuse
exigence de l'Union Européenne.
Cela ferait augmenter plus
l'âge de départ à la retraite
des femmes plutôt que les hommes.
Cela va pénaliser les carrières
longues.
Cela coûtera cher aux Français et
surtout aux femmes retraitées.
Les mesures "sociales" ne seront
pas adaptées au pays.
Le débat parlementaire, c'est la
démocratie, mais la démocratie ne
se résume pas au débat
parlementaire.
Entendez le cri de la rue.
Retirez cette réforme ou
soumettez-la au référendum.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Olivier Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Merci.
Monsieur Quatennens, vous avez
commencé en disant que le déficit
n'existait pas.
Ce n'est pas vrai.
Ce déficit est documenté.
Nous nous appuyons sur les travaux
d'orientation du conseil des
retraites.
Il y a un déficit.
Dès 2023, il va approcher les 2
milliards d'euros.
Il sera de 12,5 milliards en 2027.
Si nous ne faisons rien, ce sera
150 milliards de dettes en plus.
Personne ne veut appauvrir les
retraités de notre pays.
Si nous ne faisons rien, c'est ce
qu'il va se passer.
Le texte que vous présentez n'est
pas celui que nous présentons au
Parlement.
Il a été enrichi pour permettre
d'intégrer les amendements qui
nous ont été présentés ici, et
dont l'obstruction nous a
empêchés.
Nous voulons revaloriser les
petites pensions, valoriser les
trimestres cotisés par les femmes
et les mères de famille avec des
carrières complètes à 63 ans.
Le projet de loi tel qui vous sera
présenté est un projet enrichi et
qui protège.
Vous nous dites que ce qui compte
à nos yeux, c'est la comptabilité
et les chiffres.
C'est d'une importance capitale,
je vous le confirme.
Dans toutes les fonctions, j'ai
acquis une conviction: l'équilibre
des comptes permet d'agir.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Marie-Christine Dalloz.
- Marie-Christine Dalloz: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
Bruno Le Maire.
Le rapport public annuel de la
Cour des comptes pointe une
situation des finances publiques
en 2023 parmi les plus dégradées
de la zone euro.
Nous ne pouvons plus continuer
dans cette voie.
La cour vous exhorte à plus de
responsabilité budgétaire, sans
laquelle vous précipiterez la
France dans un gouffre dont
nous ne pourrons nous extraire.
Notre souveraineté est en péril.
La Commission européenne juge
ainsi élevé le risque pour la
soutenabilité de notre dette à
moyen terme.
Les mesures prises pour amortir le
choc inflationniste continueront
de peser à hauteur de 36 milliards
d'euros sur la dépense.
Vous persistez dans cette
politique du carnet de chèques,
qui consiste à déployer un
catalogue de mesures mal ciblées
et trop coûteuses.
A 58% du PIB, la France a les
dépenses publiques les plus
élevées de la zone euro, pour des
services publics toujours moins
efficaces.
Les dépenses hors crise continuent
parallèlement de s'envoler: + 3,5%
en volume pour 2022, hors
inflation.
Nous décrochons sur tous les
fronts et vous regardez ailleurs.
Le redressement de la trajectoire
est impératif et nécessitera une
détermination publique, politique,
dont vous n'avez jamais fait
preuve depuis 2017.
Que va-t-il arriver lorsque nous
nous retrouverons aux côtés de la
Grèce ou de l'Italie, dans le trio
de tête des pays les plus endettés
de la zone euro?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Bruno Le
Maire.
- Bruno Le Maire: Merci.
Madame la députée Marie-Christine
Dalloz, je voudrais rappeler que
lorsque nous sommes arrivés en
2017, nous avons sorti la France
d'une procédure pour déficit
excessif, rétabli les comptes
publics et nous sommes revenus
sous les 3% de déficit public.
S'agissant du rapport de la Cour
des comptes, nous partageons le
constat, d'autant plus que je le
fais depuis le mois de juin.
Nous avons commencé à rétablir nos
finances publiques parce que c'est
un impératif non négociable.
La première étape, c'est de sortir
du "quoi qu'il en coûte".
J'ai pu compter sur le soutien
d'un certain nombre d'entre vous
pour mettre fin à une remise sur
l'intégralité du carburant pour
tous les consommateurs et la
remplacer par une indemnité
carburant pour les travailleurs,
plus ciblée.
Nous avons voulu cibler également
les aides en entreprises sur
celles qui en ont plus besoin.
Certains d'entre vous voulez que
nous préservions un bouclier pour
toutes les entreprises.
Nous avons fait le choix des aides
ciblées pour sortir du quoi qu'il
en coûte.
Nous avons maintenant un objectif.
Nous avons un calendrier.
Nous avons une méthode.
L'objectif est de rappeler de près
de 58% de dépenses publiques par
rapport à notre richesse nationale
à 54%.
C'est le cap qui nous a
été fixé pour revenir sur les 3%
de déficit public en 2027.
La méthode est celle de la revue
des dépenses publiques.
Nous allons revoir chacune des
dépenses publiques de l'Etat, des
collectivités locales, des
associations, pour voir où les
économies peuvent être faites.
Je compte ici sur votre soutien,
votre vigilance et vos
propositions sur ce sujet.
Le calendrier est très précis.
Je vais recevoir le 30 mars
prochain le premier président de
la Cour des comptes pour
travailler avec lui.
Nous présenterons le programme de
stabilité le 12 avril.
Nous aurons un séminaire
gouvernemental pour réduire les
dépenses de l'Etat et nous allons
préparer à la fin juin le projet
de finances 2024.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
Madame Dalloz?
- Marie-Christine Dalloz: Un
enseignant à un élève dirait:
"Peut mieux faire."
Nous vous avons imposé un plan de
sobriété lors de l'examen du
projet de loi de finances.
Allons vers une dépense plus
efficace.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Roger
Chudeau.
- Roger Chudeau: Merci.
Monsieur le ministre de
l'Education nationale, parlons
Parcoursup et baccalauréat.
La campagne 2023 Parcoursup
s'achève.
Les élèves de terminale ont dû
faire leur choix.
Leurs notes seront capitales pour
leur orientation l'année
prochaine.
Les épreuves anticipées en mars
n'ont pas de valeur et tronquent
gravement l'année scolaire.
Il s'en suit que la maîtrise des
connaissances attendue est
partielle et ne peut être assurée.
Les notes attribuées ne peuvent
mesurer correctement la maîtrise
des enseignements.
Enfin, après ces épreuves, les
élèves se désintéressent le plus
souvent des matières qui sont
désormais sans enjeu.
L'année scolaire est pratiquement
terminée fin mars.
Le baccalauréat réformé par votre
prédécesseur n'est plus qu'une
caricature.
Ce n'est plus qu'un examen de fin
de lycée au lieu d'un examen
d'entrée à l'université.
Cet examen est de moins en moins
national et de plus en plus local.
Les taux de réussite sont
extravagants.
Les mentions sont bradées.
Il ne sert à rien du tout dans la
procédure d'orientation et
d'affectation dans le supérieur.
Cela en fait au mieux un
certificat de présence.
L'ensemble Parcoursup est un
système arbitraire et globalement
inefficace.
Qui peut s'y retrouver?
Près de 120.000 élèves restent sur
le carreau tous les ans.
50.000 bacheliers échouent en
première année d'université.
Quand allez-vous redonner sens au
baccalauréat?
Quand allez-vous remplacer
Parcoursup par une procédure plus
juste?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Pap
Ndiaye.
- Pap Ndiaye: Merci.
Monsieur le député Chudeau, pour
la première fois, en effet, les
épreuves du baccalauréat vont se
dérouler entre le 20 et le 22
mars.
Ces épreuves, contrairement à ce
que vous pensez, ont été adaptées
pour le moment,
le programme a été resserré par
l'inspection générale au mois de
septembre.
Par conséquent, les épreuves
pourront prendre en compte ce
qu'ont étudié les élèves.
D'abord, le fait de rendre au mois
de juin du temps d'enseignement,
alors que celui-ci était amputé
par l'organisation de 6 à 10
épreuves.
On rend du temps scolaire aux
élèves au mois de juin, ce qui
illustre la fameuse reconquête du
mois de juin.
Cela permet également une
meilleure prise en compte par les
établissements de l'enseignement
supérieur des résultats des
épreuves de spécialité, qui seront
pris en compte pour la première
fois par Parcoursup et redonnerons
ainsi toute sa valeur au
baccalauréat.
Jusqu'à la fin du mois de juin,
les élèves continueront ainsi à
préparer le grand oral ainsi que
l'épreuve de philosophie.
Ils pourront également se préparer
à une meilleure transition vers
l'enseignement supérieur.
Cette réforme, engagée en 2018,
vise à prendre en compte la
régularité du travail des élèves.
C'est la première fois cette année
que les épreuves du nouveau bac
auront lieu dans des conditions
normales.
A l'échelle du monde, les grands
examens de fin de secondaire se
passent dans des conditions
analogues.
Le baccalauréat était la dernière
grande épreuve à être organisée
sous forme de contrôle final.
Plutôt que de regarder dans le
rétroviseur d'un âge d'or
prétendu, regardez concrètement la
situation des élèves.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est au président
Brotherson.
- Moetai Brotherson: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse au ministre
de la Santé.
La Polynésie est une collectivité
d'outre-mer avec un statut
particulier qui a la compétence de
la santé mais bizarrement pas
celle des médicaments.
Il en résulte une situation un peu
bancale, où tout un ensemble de
plantes endémiques utilisées
depuis le fond des âges pour
soigner chez nous se retrouvent
interdites d'utilisation, parce
qu'à défaut d'être inscrites à la
pharmacopée nationale, ce qui
suppose un long processus de
reconnaissance, elles sont tout
simplement interdites, puisque
non-autorisées.
Ces plantes, ces savoirs, sont
aujourd'hui menacés, soit
d'extinction, et finalement de
disparition de la mémoire
collective faute d'utilisation, ou
sont sujettes à la biopiraterie de
grands groupes qui viennent
étudier ces plantes, déposent des
brevets et dépossèdent les
Polynésiens de leur patrimoine
naturel.
Ma question ne vise pas à opposer
le gouvernement national à la
communauté de Polynésie, mais
plutôt à savoir comment établir
des passerelles entre l'exécutif
polynésien et les exigences
compréhensibles de sûreté du
médicament, pour que cette
médecine traditionnelle puisse
trouver sa place au sein de la
République et puisse garder la
place qui est la sienne depuis le
fond des âges en Polynésie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Véran.
- Olivier Véran: Merci.
Monsieur le député Brotherson, je
comprends votre question.
La pharmacopée, pour une grande
partie d'entre elles, relève de
l'exploitation de plantes et de
racines de toute la planète.
Beaucoup de médicaments de l'usage
courant sont issus de
l'exploitation des plantes.
Ces médicaments ont franchi des
étapes de validation sur les
effets positifs, les effets
éventuellement toxiques, avec des
études qui permettent de définir
quelle est la dose précise de
telle molécule qui permet de
guérir et d'éviter d'aggraver
certaines maladies.
Il en va ainsi dans le monde
entier.
Cela ne veut pas dire qu'on ne
peut pas se poser les bonnes
questions et qu'il n'est pas
question d'exploiter tout ce qui
peut l'être sur la planète, y
compris en matière de plantes
issues de la Polynésie française.
Le gouvernement est engagé pour
pouvoir favoriser l'exploitation
scientifique de toutes les
ressources naturelles des
territoires ultramarins.
On accompagne en cela les
scientifiques, les laboratoires,
pour pouvoir le faire.
Est-ce qu'on peut avoir une
reconnaissance dérogatoire, sans
passer par les fourches caudines
de l'Agence nationale de sécurité
des médicaments pour reconnaître
une plante comme médicament?
Je suis obligé de vous répondre
non.
En revanche, s'il s'agit de savoir
comment vous aider à faire
reconnaître au mieux les
indications éventuelles de telle
ou telle plante dans telle ou
telle pathologie, nous avons
l'intention de pouvoir accompagner
l'exploitation de la flore
polynésienne.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Sarah
Tanzilli.
- Sarah Tanzilli: Je vous
remercie.
Ma question s'adresse à madame la
ministre des Affaires étrangères.
93 jours.
Depuis 93 jours, 120.000 hommes,
femmes et enfants vivent coupés du
monde.
L'Altar est devenu une prison à
ciel ouvert.
Cette complicité entre
l'Azerbaïdjan et la Russie a été
signée quelques jours avant
l'invasion de l'Ukraine.
Bakou a signé, comme par miracle,
un accord avec Ursula von der
Leyen pour tripler ses exports de
gaz vers l'Union Européenne.
C'est bien du gaz russe que
l'Union Européenne achète à
l'Azerbaïdjan.
Du gaz russe pour remplacer du gaz
russe et pour financer les canons
pointés sur les Arméniens.
La semaine dernière, la situation
a franchi un nouveau palier.
L'armée azerbaïdjanaise a attaqué
un véhicule en zone arménienne,
faisant trois morts.
On ne parle pas d'un conflit
territorial.
Ce qui se passe depuis 93 jours
dans une relative indifférence est
un drame humanitaire.
Ce qui attend cette zone, c'est un
nettoyage ethnique rendu possible
grâce à ces accords gaziers.
Le président de la République est
au courant de ces menaces.
Notre diplomatie est pour beaucoup
dans le déploiement d'une mission
d'observation.
Mais les gens se meurent.
Je crois pouvoir associer toute la
représentation nationale à ma
question.
Quand allons-nous tirer les
conséquences en sanctionnant les
responsables de ce blocus criminel
et mettre un terme aux accords
gaziers conclus par l'Union
Européenne qui appuient la
complicité entre Russie et
Azerbaïdjan?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Colonna.
- Catherine Colonna: Cette
situation nous préoccupe.
J'ai dénoncé ici même, le 28
février, ce blocage et les
conséquences humanitaires
dramatiques qui s'ensuivent.
Après le grave événement du 5 mars
auquel vous avez fait référence,
nous avons demandé une enquête
transparente.
Nous avons également demandé que
ses conclusions soient rendues
publiques.
Nous souhaitons par ailleurs que
l'approvisionnement des
populations du Haut-Karabakh soit
rétabli et que le rétablissement
des infrastructures aboutisse.
La décision de la cour
internationale de justice doit
être immédiatement appliquée.
Cette cour ne manquera pas d'en
tenir compte dans sa décision, qui
va suivre cette décision en
référé.
L'Union Européenne et la
communauté internationale, par
l'intermédiaire des Nations Unies,
pourront en tirer les
conséquences.
Par ailleurs, l'Union Européenne
est attentive aux risques de
contournement des sanctions visant
la Russie.
Elle doit renforcer sa vigilance.
Nous y travaillons.
La France est sans doute le pays
le plus engagé dans la défense des
Arméniens.
Avec l'Union Européenne, avec les
Etats-Unis, nos contacts sont
permanents avec l'Arménie et
l'Azerbaïdjan, pour parvenir à un
accord de paix et faire en sorte
que les populations du
Haut-Karabakh puissent y vivre
dans le respect de leur histoire,
de leur culture et de leur
dignité.
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur David
Taupiac.
- David Taupiac: Merci.
Monsieur le ministre de la Santé,
c'est avec colère que j'ai appris
au détour de la presse, il y a
quelques jours, la fermeture à
très court terme de la clinique de
Gascogne, dans le Gers.
En décembre dernier, je vous ai
interrogé ici même à ce sujet.
Vous avez pourtant pris
l'engagement de nous tenir au
courant de l'évolution du dossier.
Depuis, pas de nouvelles, ni au
courrier que je vous ai remis lors
de votre visite dans le Gers, et
pas davantage sur les solutions
envisagées par l'ARS.
En conséquence, la mise en place
de protocoles d'accord assortis de
délais trop courts ne pouvait
mener qu'à un échec programmé.
Que proposez-vous face à l'urgence
de la situation?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Olivier Véran.
- Olivier Véran: Monsieur le
député Taupiac, vous interrogez le
ministre de la Santé, qui n'est
pas présent ici.
Au mois de janvier, le ministre de
la Santé avait été invité...
François Braun avait été envoyé
par le député Jean-René Cazeneuve
sur le territoire gersois pour
parler de l'accès aux soins et de
l'organisation entre hôpitaux et
cliniques privées du territoire.
Il me semble que la situation pour
la clinique soit compliquée.
Elle a été subventionnée.
Elle a été aidée par l'Agence
régionale de santé, notamment.
Il en est ressorti que, quelle que
soit l'issue, il y a un principe
que nous devons respecter: il faut
que l'offre de soins, notamment
celle du parc hospitalier pour les
patients de ce territoire, soit
maintenue en toute sécurité,
continuité et qualité.
Ainsi, des propositions ont déjà
été faites par l'hôpital mais
aussi par des cliniques voisines
pour reprendre l'organisation des
soins sur ce territoire.
Tout ceci, en coordonant les
choses et en consultant
massivement.
Soyez assurés de la détermination
du gouvernement pour que nous
puissions mettre en place avec
vous aussi, monsieur le député
Taupiac, une offre de soins
acceptable et satisfaisante.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
Monsieur Taupiac?
- David Taupiac: Vous ne prenez
pas la mesure de la situation.
L'urgence est de trouver une
solution pour éviter de faire
perdre au département 60% de son
offre chirurgicale et le
licenciement d'une centaine de
salariés.
Des patients sont atteints de
maladies graves.
La déprogrammation d'opérations
vitales pour eux continue.
Il faut reprendre la main sur ce
dossier, géré par des bureaucrates
sur une logique comptable.
Il faut un médiateur extérieur
neutre et un moratoire pour
maintenir l'activité de la
clinique, le temps de poursuivre
l'examen des propositions.
Le coût ne serait rien, compte
tenu de celui qui serait celui de
demain pour acheminer les patients
en cas de fermeture de la clinique
dans d'autres centres.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Murielle
Lepvraud.
- Murielle Lepvraud: Merci.
Monsieur le ministre de la Santé,
chers collègues, qui aurait pu
prédire la crise du système
hospitalier?
Tous les gouvernements qui se sont
succédé ces dernières années ont
oeuvré avec succès pour notre
système de santé publique.
Alors, pourquoi les hôpitaux ne
subsistent qu'avec l'aide des
intérimaires, qui choisissent de
travailler ainsi, car ils peuvent
aménager leur temps de travail en
étant grassement rémunérés, ce qui
porte préjudice aux budgets des
hôpitaux?
Partout en France, de nombreuses
maternités sont menacées de
fermeture.
Le rapport présenté récemment à
l'Académie de médecine préconise
la fermeture des 111 maternités
qui ne pratiqueraient pas mille
accouchements par an.
A Guingamp, on est passés de 300,
puis 500, à 1000 accouchements
sans raison valable, si ce n'est
de bâtir des usines à bébés.
Mais on prive les femmes de
l'accès aux soins.
C'est également une atteinte à
leurs droits de disposer de leur
corps que de leur imposer des
kilomètres pour finir dans une
chambre d'hôtel puis dans une
usine.
Quel monde nous imposez-vous?
La loi qui vise à plafonner les
rémunérations des intérimaires,
adoptée en 2021, a été repoussée
parce qu'il n'était pas possible à
l'époque de l'appliquer.
Pourquoi serait-ce possible le 3
avril prochain?
Le principe est bon, mais rien n'a
été fait.
Les conditions ne sont pas plus
favorables aujourd'hui.
Avez-vous amélioré les conditions
de travail dans les hôpitaux
publics par rapport au secteur
privé?
Avez-vous régulé l'installation
des médecins sur les territoires?
Avez-vous rétabli l'astreinte pour
les nuits et les week-ends?
L'application de cette loi,
nécessaire, nous inquiète, car
elle menace l'existence de
nombreux services hospitaliers de
proximité.
Monsieur le ministre, qu'avez-vous
prévu pour que la loi puisse
s'appliquer sans fermer les
hôpitaux de territoires ruraux
et sans fermer nos
maternités?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Véran.
- Olivier Véran: Merci.
Je ne m'attendais pas, de la part
d'une députée de La France
Insoumise, à entendre la défense
d'une rémunération dans le secteur
public qui dépasserait les 1200
euros par jour.
Le plafonnement dont il est
question est un plafonnement à
1170 euros par 24 heures.
Il faut revoir l'échelle de
valeurs.
Il faut pouvoir l'appliquer.
C'est nécessaire pour assainir la
situation.
Personne ne nie les difficultés
qu'il y a à conserver les médecins
dans les hôpitaux.
Quand on parle de 1170 euros par
jour, si.
On ne va pas aligner les
rémunérations dans le secteur
public à 20.000 euros par mois
pour conserver les médecins!
Vous faites le mélange avec un
rapport de l'Académie de médecine,
qui est une autorité indépendante
et qui propose d'augmenter le
seuil d'accouchements pour
maintenir la qualité et la
sécurité et la continuité des
soins dans une maternité à mille
accouchements par an.
Nous en tenons compte pour engager
une réflexion sur l'avenir du
système périnatal dans notre pays.
Nous le faisons régulièrement,
comme quand nous avons revu à la
hausse les missions et les
rémunérations des sages femmes.
Nous avons mis en place des
maisons de naissance pour répondre
à la demande des parturientes
d'accoucher en dehors des
structures très médicalisées.
Mes oreilles saignent quand je
vous entends parler "d'usines à
bébés".
Pour avoir des maternités qui font
1500, ou 2000 accouchements, c'est
très insultant pour ce pays et
pour les femmes françaises qui
accouchent.
Je ne pense pas qu'elles aient
l'impression d'accoucher dans des
usines à bébés.
A force d'être excessifs dans la
parole et le verbe pour essayer
d'attaquer systématiquement le
gouvernement quand il n'est pas en
cause, vous tapez à côté.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Frédéric
Valletoux.
- Frédéric Valletoux: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à madame la
ministre chargée de la
Citoyenneté.
22 ans après l'adoption d'une loi,
je salue la mesure du gouvernement
visant à lutter contre les dérives
sectaires.
Oui, l'action de l'Etat doit
s'adapter à l'évolution de ce
phénomène.
L'Etat doit sévir contre ces
charlatans qui profitent des
personnes malades ou fragiles.
Il faut encadrer les pratiques de
soins non-conventionnels, comme la
naturopathie, qui prolifèrent
depuis la crise sanitaire.
La santé est aujourd'hui une porte
d'entrée des dérives sectaires et
un moyen pour de nombreux
mouvements d'attirer de nouveaux
adeptes.
La MIVILUDES dénombre près de 4000
thérapeutes autoproclamés.
Prétextant l'inutilité des
traitements non-conventionnels, le
pseudo-praticien va demander au
patient d'avoir toute confiance en
lui car il serait le seul apte à
le guérir.
Des personnes fragilisées par les
maladies ou en situation difficile
peuvent être happées par ces
pseudo-thérapeutes.
Ces dérives peuvent brûler encore
plus l'accès aux soins pour nos
concitoyens.
Pouvez-vous nous indiquer quelles
mesures précises vont être prises
pour lutter contre les dérives
sectaires dans le domaine de la
santé et notamment contre les
pratiques de soins non
conventionnelles?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
- Sonia Backès: Je vous remercie.
Les signalements explosent en
matière de dérives sectaires.
Des dizaines de milliers de
personnes sont concernées par ces
dérives.
Votre question concerne en
particulier le domaine de la santé
et c'est le domaine dans lequel
l'explosion des signalements est
la plus importante.
C'est un des domaines sur lesquels
nous avons eu les propositions les
plus fortes.
La première proposition, celle qui
a été annoncée par la ministre
déléguée auprès du ministre de la
Santé, est celle qui annonce
l'encadrement des pratiques
non-conventionnelles de soins.
Cela va permettre aux Français de
savoir s'ils peuvent aller voir un
praticien en confiance ou non.
Un certain nombre de propositions
ont été faites en matière de
santé, notamment l'interdiction de
la publicité de ces pratiques
non-conventionnelles de soins des
maladies graves, la mise en place
d'un délit d'incitation à l'arrêt
du traitement médical, et la
possibilité éventuelle pour les
agences régionales de santé
d'interdire d'exercer pour les
thérapeutes déviants.
Les moyens de la MIVILUDES vont
être augmentés de 25%.
Cela va concerner à la fois la
prévention, puisque nous avons
besoin d'alerter les Français pour
qu'ils évitent de rentrer dans ces
dérives, avec un travail qui va
être mené avec les plates-formes
de réseaux sociaux, un travail de
communication également ainsi
qu'un travail sur les victimes,
qui
veut accompagner.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Emmanuel
Blairy.
- Emmanuel Blairy: Ma question
s'adresse à Marc Fesneau.
Il y a 212 ans, jour pour jour,
Napoléon a poussé une politique
pour le développement du sucre.
La situation dans laquelle se
retrouvent nos betteraviers est
grave.
En 2013, la Commission européenne
annonce la suspension de certaines
substances insecticides, et le
gouvernement de l'époque fait du
zèle en accentuant les règles
européennes.
On n'en peut plus, de ces
décisions dogmatiques.
On en découvre chaque jour les
conséquences.
Il y a eu des erreurs et des choix
énergétiques sur la filière du
nucléaire, et maintenant, c'est
l'agriculture qui est frappée.
Nous voyons apparaître des effets
désastreux.
Une sucrerie va être supprimée,
avec 123 postes.
On assiste, impuissants, au déclin
français pour le grand bénéfice du
voisin allemand.
Le Rassemblement National est pris
de cohérence collective, mais
jamais au détriment des Français.
Notre souveraineté doit être
absolue.
Gouverner, c'est prévoir.
Outre ce plan d'une vision à court
terme, quelles mesures pérennes
comptez-vous prendre pour que les
producteurs de betteraves puissent
consolider la filière?
- Comme toujours, quand il s'agit
d'évoquer des problèmes, vous êtes
présent, mais pour les solutions,
vous manquez à l'appel.
Je suis allé dans le Nord pour
évoquer la fermeture potentielle
de l'entreprise de betteraves à
sucre.
Le Front National manquait à
l'appel hier alors que nous
discutions sur vos territoires.
Vous criez, mais quand il s'agit
de trouver des solutions et de
mettre la pression sur les
entreprises pour que, plutôt que
de fermer des usines qui gagnent
de l'argent, on les incite à
fédérer la filière et à travailler
avec les producteurs de betteraves
pour que les semences soient plus
élevées et pour que la production
soit plus élevée.
Là encore, vous manquez à l'appel.
J'ai été président de la
commission qui a permis aux
producteurs de betteraves de
continuer leur production.
Nous soutenons la filière.
Je souhaite que celles et ceux qui
sont impliqués dans cette filière
et qui profitent du prix du sucre
puissent prendre leurs
responsabilités pour que
l'ensemble de la filière soit
gagnante.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Monsieur le
député?
- Emmanuel Blairy: Si rien n'est
fait, au-delà du bla-bla, c'est
tout un savoir-faire qui risque de
disparaître.
On ira chercher notre sucre en
Allemagne, en Amérique latine,
sans parler des conséquences en
matière de carbone.
A quand le retour du bon sens
paysan?
C'est la vraie question.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Pascal Lecamp.
- Pascal Lecamp: Chers collègues,
ma question s'adresse au ministre
de l'Economie et des Finances,
Bruno Le Maire.
Vendredi dernier, la Silicon
Valley Bank a fait faillite.
Cette défaillance est la plus
importante depuis la grande
récession de 2009.
A cela s'ajoute celle de la banque
spécialisée en cryptomonnaie.
Je vous remercie pour votre
première réponse rassurant sur la
solidité de notre système
bancaire.
Depuis 2008, nous avons eu un
cadre rassurant avec la création
d'un mécanisme pour prévenir de la
liquidité et un meilleur
encadrement des activités de
marché qui doivent conforter la
résistance de nos banques.
La première phase de l'Union
bancaire à l'échelle européenne a
revu notre système de supervision,
le rendant plus sûr et efficace
que celui des Etats-Unis.
Des inquiétudes subsistent.
Les différents marchés financiers
ont fortement vacillé depuis
lundi.
Plusieurs voix se sont élevées
pour nous alerter du risque d'une
nouvelle crise financière
mondiale, faisant craindre de
revivre le cauchemar de 2009-2012.
Cette faillite n'est-elle pas une
piqûre de rappel quant à la
nécessité d'achever enfin l'Union
bancaire et de mettre en place une
véritable garantie européenne des
dépôts, de protéger mieux nos
concitoyens sans risquer de
fragiliser les finances publiques
de chacun des Etats-membres?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Bruno Le Maire.
- Bruno Le Maire: Monsieur le
député Pascal Lecamp, il y a une
leçon à retenir de cette faillite
de la banque régionale américaine,
c'est que la prudence est mère de
toutes les vertus, en particulier
en matière bancaire.
Cette banque s'est exposée au seul
secteur financier de la banque.
Donald Trump a exonéré les banques
régionales d'Amérique pour que
tiennent un certain nombre
d'obligations, notamment en cas de
moins-values latentes.
Elles étaient de plus en plus
évidentes puisque les taux
d'intérêt augmentaient et que
c'est donc avec des taux fixes
très
de poursuivre.
Nous avons mis en place le
mécanisme européen de supervision,
le fonds de résolution unique à 75
millions d'euros, et nous avons
donc renforcé les dispositifs de
supervision européen, le mécanisme
européen est plus puissant, plus
solide et plus protecteur que le
mécanisme de supervision retenu
par les Etats-Unis.
Je partage votre avis, il faut
continuer dans cette direction et
s'attaquer à la mise en place
d'une union bancaire qui ne touche
pas que la supervision, mais aussi
les mécanismes de dépôt.
J'espère que nous parviendrons à
un résultat.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Christine Arrighi.
- Christine Arrighi: Madame
la ministre de la Transition
énergétique, nous avons découvert
la décision du gouvernement de
rassembler les organisations.
Plusieurs directeurs d'organismes
ont participé à un comité.
Les approches étaient
différenciées.
L'un a plaidé pour la réforme, et
l'autre a indiqué qu'elle le
conformerait.
D'autres se sont exprimés en
faveur de la préservation du
système actuel.
L'ancien président de l'OPEC
estimait qu'il y avait une
méconnaissance grave et qu'en
changer serait un retour en
arrière de 30 ans.
Un chercheur a indiqué que ce
projet risquerait d'affaiblir la
légitimité du système de sécurité
auprès des citoyens.
L'OPEC est resté dans
l'interrogation qui était la
sienne avant les audits, à savoir:
"Cette réforme irait-elle si
vite?"
Pourquoi mettre la charrue avant
les boeufs?
Pourquoi ne pas faire précéder
cette réforme d'une phase de
diagnostic et d'étude d'impact
suivie d'une phase de négociation?
Dans l'hypothèse où vous ne
reviendriez pas sur votre mission,
quelles sont vos options si les
rapports commandés remettaient en
cause votre projet, eu égard aux
multiples réserves déjà exprimées?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Agnès
Pannier-Runacher.
- Agnès Pannier-Runacher: Merci.
Je vais remettre cette réforme de
la sûreté nucléaire dans son
contexte plus général.
Le grand combat de ce siècle, au
niveau du gouvernement, est de
sortir notre pays des énergies
fossiles.
Pour cela, il y a deux
possibilités: baisser notre
consommation d'énergie, et nous y
travaillons avec la sobriété
énergétique, et produire plus
d'électricité bas carbone.
Il y a un projet de loi que vous
n'avez pas voté à ce sujet.
C'est aussi avoir plus de
nucléaire et faire face au
remplacement de nos réacteurs
nucléaires, qui vont arriver un
jour à leur terme.
Si vous aviez la gentillesse de me
laisser parler...
A l'aube du lancement d'un des
plus grands programmes de
réacteurs nucléaires que nous
sommes en train de fortifier, nous
mettrons en place les briques de
l'énergie nucléaire.
Cela nous amène à regrouper les
forces de l'autorité de sûreté
nucléaire.
De quoi s'agit-il?
De réunir les forces sous une même
bannière d'autorité administrative
indépendante de ces deux
organismes pour être enfin au
niveau des grandes organisations
qui assurent la sûreté nucléaire
dans les autres pays qui ont des
grands programmes nucléaires.
La France a une des autorités de
sûreté nucléaire qui a le plus
faible nombre d'employés.
Vous le savez?
En quoi est-il problématique de
réunir sous cette bannière
indépendante l'ensemble des forces
au service de cette ambition
nucléaire?
L'expertise et la recherche seront
préservées.
Le projet de loi élargit les
missions de l'ASN et sécurise le
parcours des agents...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
- Christine Arrighi: Vous n'avez
pas répondu à ma question.
Que ferez-vous si, à l'issue du
rapport que vous avez demandé, il
était indiqué, au regard des
multiples réserves exprimées, que
l'absorption de ces organismes
n'était pas une bonne idée?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Isabelle Santiago.
- Isabelle Santiago: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse au ministre
des Solidarités.
En France, plus de 1 enfant sur 5
vit en situation de pauvreté.
Nous n'avons jamais connu une
aggravation si rapide de la
précarité.
Les indicateurs de pauvreté sont
au rouge et doivent nous alerter.
En décembre dernier, on comptait
plus de 1300 enfants sans solution
d'hébergement, un record
tristement historique.
Le dernier rapport de la Fondation
Abbé Pierre montre que les enfants
qui vivent dans les logements
insalubres se comptent par
centaines de milliers.
Concernant l'alimentation, on
observe une hausse de plus de 30%
des bébés inscrits à l'aide
alimentaire en Ile-de-France, les
Restos du Coeur pour la campagne
hiver 2023.
Il y a en France 110.000 bébés
pris en charge par les Restos du
Coeur, à l'heure où la campagne
vient de se finir, vendredi
dernier.
Que vont-ils devenir?
Quelles réponses apportons-nous à
cette urgence?
Avec l'inflation qui s'aggrave en
mars et qui est déjà à un très
haut niveau, si on regarde le
nombre de bénéficiaires, dont les
enfants de moins de 5 ans sur
l'ensemble des grandes
associations caritatives
nationales, il y a de quoi être en
urgence absolue pour répondre à ce
défi de bien grandir.
La grande pauvreté des enfants
n'est pas une fatalité.
La politique est un art du
possible.
C'est trouver des solutions sur un
plan ambitieux.
En 2021, lors de la présidence de
l'Union Européenne, les
Etats-membres ont adopté une
garantie européenne de l'enfance
visant à lutter contre la pauvreté
des enfants.
J'appelle le gouvernement à la
prendre en compte et à en
appliquer les recommandations.
C'était l'objet de notre tribune
signée avec la présidente de
l'Unicef ce dimanche.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Jean-Christophe Combe.
- Jean-Christophe Combe: Merci.
Madame la députée Santiago, j'ai
reçu il y a quelques jours la
présidente d'Unicef France pour
faire le point sur la situation.
Je rejoins un certain nombre de
vos constats, notamment le fait
que dans notre pays, un trop grand
nombre d'enfants sont victimes de
pauvreté et d'exclusion sociale.
Vous avez rappelé que ces
dernières années, l'action du
gouvernement a cherché à réduire
la pauvreté des enfants dans notre
pays.
Cela a permis, pendant la crise
sanitaire, d'éviter une explosion
de la pauvreté et de maintenir un
taux de pauvreté et de progression
à un taux relativement stable.
Il faut continuer à agir.
C'est le constat que la pauvreté
dans notre pays fait face à un
déterminisme important.
Nous avons construit des mesures
pour répondre à la pauvreté des
enfants.
Ca a été le cas avec le
dédoublement des classes de CP et
de CE1 dans les zones d'éducation
prioritaire.
Il y a aussi eu le bonus de la
mixité sociale dans les crèches et
avec les subventions du
gouvernement à la cantine, avec
les repas à 1 euro.
On ne va pas s'arrêter là.
Je vais présenter un pacte de
solidarité qui a été construit
avec mes collègues du gouvernement
pour répondre à cette question
dans toutes ses dimensions, un
pacte qui va permettre de répondre
à ces problématiques.
Il faudra poursuivre le travail
d'accès à une alimentation de
qualité et prévenir les inégalités
sociales de santé et le décrochage
scolaire, ou encore garantir
l'accès à des temps libres
favorisant l'épanouissement des
enfants.
Nous le porterons au niveau
européen.
La France a été un des premiers
pays à mettre en place la garantie
européenne pour l'enfance.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Philippe Juvin.
- Philippe Juvin: Merci.
Madame la présidente, cette
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'Economie.
Je voudrais revenir sur cette
question très grave de la faillite
de la Silicon Valley Bank.
Cette faillite n'est pas un
accident.
C'est la crise d'un système dans
lequel nous avons tous vécu, celui
de l'argent soi-disant gratuit.
C'est aussi le signe que toutes
les banques, petites ou grandes,
ont des effets systémiques et
qu'elles doivent être regardées
comme ayant des effets systémiques
sur toute l'économie par le
régulateur.
Il est vrai que les banques
françaises sont mieux protégées.
Le législateur national et
européen a multiplié les règles
prudentielles, qui font
qu'aujourd'hui, la liquidité et
les garanties sont plus
importantes en Europe, surtout en
France.
Il y a toutefois des trous dans la
raquette européenne.
En particulier, quand il y a eu
les débats au Parlement et au
Conseil européen, les banques
régionales allemandes, mais aussi
espagnoles ou italiennes, ont
échappé, pour une partie, aux
régulations très dures qui sont
imposées aux banques françaises.
Là-dessus se rajoute une
fragmentation immense du marché.
Tout cela fait qu'il y a une
complexité d'application soulignée
par la Cour des comptes
européenne.
Pouvez-vous imaginer demander à la
Commission européenne un test de
toutes les banques régionales?
Votre première arme, c'est la
confiance.
Seriez-vous prêt à étudier
l'augmentation du seuil de
garantie des dépôts bancaires des
épargnants?
Il faudrait demander à ce que
l'abondement du fonds de
résolution unique, c'est-à-dire la
caisse de garantie des épargnants,
soit repoussé au-delà de 2023.
A la fin de 2023, le fonds de
résolution unique devrait cesser
d'être abondé.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Bruno Le Maire.
- Bruno Le Maire: Merci.
Je partage votre analyse.
Je crois que les Européens ont
tiré toutes les leçons de la crise
financière de 2008 pour renforcer
la protection du système bancaire
et des banques européennes, en
particulier.
Nous avons désormais une
protection solide.
Il n'y a pas de risque sur les
banques françaises, pas de risque
sur les systèmes bancaires
français.
Je veux le dire à tous les
épargnants et entrepreneurs qui
ont déposé leurs fonds auprès des
banques françaises.
S'agissant du montant des fonds
propres qui ont été exigés des
banques françaises, il a doublé
pour arriver à 550 milliards
d'euros depuis la crise de 2008
pour renforcer le ratio de
solvabilité des banques
françaises.
Ce ratio existe pour les banques
françaises, mais aussi pour les
banques européennes.
Il ne s'applique pas pour les
banques régionales américaines.
Il ne s'applique pas non plus aux
Donc, quand elles placent sur un
mauvais placement et qu'il y a des
pertes alors il n'y a pas de
protection collatérale.
Il faut aller plus loin sur les
mécanismes européens.
Nous avons tout intérêt à
renforcer l'Union bancaire.
Nous l'avons fait avec le
mécanisme de supervision unique.
Le fonds de résolution unique, 75
milliards d'euros, c'est un
deuxième progrès.
A chaque fois, la France participe
et paye pour ce fonds de
résolution unique.
En revanche, qu'il y ait des
systèmes de résolution en cas de
crise bancaire, nous y sommes très
favorables pour que ce soient
d'abord les actionnaires qui
payent en cas de défaillance.
Les banques, et pas le
contribuable.
C'est la prochaine étape.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à François Buffet.
- François Buffet: Merci.
Depuis vendredi, un vent de
panique s'est emparé du marché
boursier.
La Silicon Valley Bank a fait
faillite.
Cette banque spécialisée dans le
financement du numérique semblait
solide avec 209 milliards de
dollars d'actifs pour 175
milliards de dépôts au 31 décembre
2022.
Elle n'est pas parvenue à faire
face aux retraits massifs de ses
principaux clients.
La hausse des taux directeurs de
banques centrales imposés par
l'inflation a eu un double effet
préjudiciable: les entreprises
technologiques se sont retrouvées
incapables de lever des fonds et
ont puisé dans leurs liquidités,
puis les obligations qui
constituaient une part importante
des actifs ont été dépréciées au
moment même où la banque a dû les
vendre pour répondre aux besoins
de cash des clients.
Deux autres institutions ont été
entraînées dans sa chute.
La crainte d'une propagation
systémique est réelle.
La Bourse de Paris a perdu 2,9%,
celle de Francfort, 3,04%, et
celle de Londres, 2,58%.
L'indice de référence des banques
européennes a chuté de 10,2%.
Face à cette situation, la
secrétaire américaine au Trésor a
indiqué tout mettre en oeuvre pour
éviter que ces faillites ne se
propagent au reste du système
bancaire, garantissant
l'intégralité des dépôts.
Les fonds nécessaires vont être
prêtés à d'autres banques qui en
auraient besoin pour honorer les
demandes de retrait de leurs
clients.
Vous avez réagi par un appel au
calme, avant une réunion des
ministres des Finances à
Bruxelles.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci, chère
collègue.
- Bruno Le Maire: Merci, madame
Buffet.
La preuve que nos appels au calme
ont été entendus, c'est que la
Bourse de Paris s'est redressée.
Il n'y a pas de risque sur les
banques françaises.
J'ai réuni ce matin l'ensemble des
dirigeants des banques françaises
et le gouverneur de la Banque de
France pour faire un point avec
eux sur la situation.
Le gouverneur de la Banque de
France m'a confirmé que nous
n'avons pas de risque sur les
banques françaises ni de risque
sur le financement de l'économie
française.
Je voulais voir ce point avec lui
sur la BNP, le Crédit Agricole, la
Banque postale et toute autre
grande banque française.
Il n'y a pas de risque sur le
financement de l'économie
française ou sur le financement
plus global de notre économie.
Nous continuerons à suivre de très
près l'évolution de la situation.
Les préoccupations importent plus
sur les Etats-Unis que sur
l'Europe.
La réponse apportée par les
Etats-Unis était immédiate, forte.
Nous verrons si cette réponse
suffit à circonscrire la situation
aux Etats-Unis.
Je le souhaite, mais nous ne
voyons pas de risque sur les
banques françaises ni de risque de
contagion sur les banques
européennes.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Christine Engrand.
- Christine Engrand: Merci.
Madame la présidente, chers
collègues, en 2021, la loi climat
et résilience a été promulguée.
Le principe drague derrière lui
son lot de paradoxes.
Un sondage mené par l'IFOP révèle
que 80% de nos concitoyens
souhaitent vivre dans une maison
avec un jardin.
Peu importe si l'INSEE propose de
construire des logements d'ici
2030, le Sénat démontre que votre
objectif ampute les nouveaux
logements qui devraient être mis
en place.
L'artificialisation des sols varie
de 16.000 à 61.000 ha par an.
Peu importe que vous ayez instauré
un climat de l'étude chez les élus
qui souhaitent attirer de nouveaux
habitants, mais qui sont
découragés de construire à cause
des sols.
Nombreux doivent supporter l'ajout
de 15 ha dans les zones d'activité
et au détriment des terres
agricoles que vous prétendez
protéger et contre l'avis des
habitants.
L'objectif de zéro
artificialisation nette ne
pourrait pas être mis en place.
Entre la décroissance de la France
ou le renoncement à ce projet
fantasmagorie, que faites-vous?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Dominique Faure.
- Dominique Faure: Merci.
Avec Christophe Béchu, nous sommes
au travail depuis juillet 2022
pour travailler sur cet objectif à
l'horizon 2050 que nous pose la
loi climat et résilience avec le
zéro artificialisation nette.
Cette lutte doit être soutenable.
Personne ne met en cause cet
enjeu.
Nous travaillons depuis juillet
avec les associations d'élus, avec
les parlementaires pour travailler
sur des ajustements, des
évolutions.
Nous sommes d'accord pour amender
légèrement ce dispositif.
Nous avons abordé cette discussion
depuis l'été 2022 dans un esprit
d'ouverture.
Nous avons entendu plusieurs
choses, à la fois la nécessité de
se donner du temps pour
co-construire ces projets.
Nous avons entendu la demande de
territoires ruraux pour avoir une
capacité minimale de
développement.
Nous sommes en train d'y
travailler.
Christophe Béchu est au Sénat pour
répondre au sénateur Blanc.
Nous avons entendu ce besoin de
décompter les projets d'envergure
nationale et européenne.
Tous ces enjeux et ces débats dans
le cadre de ce sujet vont être
entendus.
Vous voulez parler de brutalité
froide, de faire une croix sur les
services essentiels?
C'est ma 53e visite dans nos
départements depuis l'été.
J'écoute.
Je suis sûre qu'après ces travaux,
nous allons concilier les enjeux
de la transition écologique qui
traversent notre société et les
préoccupations légitimes de nos
élus.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Arnaud Le Gall.
- Arnaud Le Gall: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de l'Economie et des
Finances.
La Silicon Valley Bank affichait
210 milliards d'euros la semaine
dernière, et elle s'est effondrée.
Vos déclarations comme quoi il n'y
aurait pas de lien entre
l'effondrement des banques aux
Etats-Unis et en Europe n'ont pas
empêché l'effondrement du CAC 40.
Pourquoi les joueurs de casino
feraient-ils confiance aux
croupiers quand tous les
ingrédients d'une crise sont
réunis?
Les acteurs savent que les
politiques appliquées en Europe et
en France sont similaires à la
situation des Etats-Unis.
La faillite de la Silicon Valley
Bank trouve ses origines dans le
déversement massif d'argent
gratuit pendant la pandémie.
Comme le dit le FMI, l'inflation
ne vient pas d'une boucle
salaire-prime, mais d'une boucle
pénurie-profit.
Faire payer aux plus pauvres
l'inflation menace de provoquer
une nouvelle crise dont les effets
seraient incommensurables sur
notre économie.
Il faut changer de politique
économique et monétaire.
Allez-vous mener le bras de fer
pour que la banque européenne
change ses conditions?
Ne voyez-vous pas dans le
cataclysme une nouvelle menace
d'abandonner la réforme des
retraites, qui créerait plus de
chômage?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Bruno Le Maire.
- Bruno Le Maire: Quand nous
sommes partis de la Silicon Valley
Bank pour aller jusqu'à la Banque
centrale européenne et finir par
l'inflation et la réforme des
retraites, nous pouvons dire que
vous avez parcouru un chemin qui
est assez vaste.
Je suis surpris de votre
fascination pour les Etats-Unis
d'Amérique.
Le système américain n'a rien à
voir avec le système européen.
Nous défendons le système européen
parce qu'il est plus protecteur.
Il repose sur une base d'actifs
très diversifiés alors qu'en
Amérique, il y a uniquement les
valeurs de la technologie.
Nous exigeons qu'il y ait du
capital à chaque fois en
contrepartie des risques pris par
les banques.
Nous refusons que les banques
soient exposées à un seul type
d'actifs.
Cela entraîne un écart de taux qui
provoque parfois des faillites,
comme ça a été le cas.
Donald Trump a fait le choix de ne
pas étendre le système de
supervision bancaire aux banques
régionales américaines.
Vous défendez les choix faits par
Donald Trump?
Nous défendons les choix faits par
l'Europe et la Banque centrale
européenne.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous en
prie, cher collègue.
- Arnaud Le Gall: Les Français
verront la valeur
de votre réponse caricaturale.